fans of the loud house have written some
pretty incredible fanfiction pieces that
bring Lincoln and his sisters into
worlds we never could have imagined here
art in loud house fan fiction crossovers
that are even better than the original
show you won't believe which universe
allowed house fan chose to write their
story in ladybug and shat loud Lincoln
loud and Ronny in Santiago have a big
secret to keep from their large families
due to an act of kindness they were
gifted kwame's by an old man on the
street Ronnie got Tiki and Lincoln got
plague they opened their boxes in secret
and quickly discovered that these
kwame's can transform them
Ronnie becomes the miraculous ladybug
and Lincoln becomes cat noir meanwhile
at a beauty pageant downtown Lola has
just lost the crown to her rival
hawkmoth consents Lola's negative
feelings and sends an evil Akuma her way
Lola transforms into an evil cosmetic
queen with the intent of ruling over
royal woods Ronnie and Lincoln run into
each other as their superhero selves
they give each other's superhero names
Lincoln calls Ronnie ladybug and Ronnie
calls Lincoln Chat Noir they must come
together to fight Lincoln sister who is
spraying everyone in sight with a
perfume that makes them instantly love
her
ladybug uses a mirror to distract
cosmetic Queen catch the Akuma and de
vil eyes it after that
Lola goes back to normal and all as well
in royal woods
we love this crossover story by now dog
two two three four four is this where
you grew up a tangled web we cut the
fanfiction Arthur who goes by the handle
the Cowardly Christian wrote a fun and
crossover piece about the loud house and
the star versus the forces of evil in
this story Marco and hecka pooh get
married and have 11 kids
Lincoln Diaz is one of those 11 children
he is described as a humanist boy with
white hair and horns Marco introduces
Starr to Lincoln and the rest of his
children all the loud house siblings
have infiltrated Stars world the kids
meet glossary who they refer to as
grandpa they climb all over him and feed
him pudding shortly after that Romulus
shows up and freezes Marco in a crystal
in ink
kapu tells the kids to say hi to their
uncle ramblas talk about a strange
family reunion the kids tack around the
lists completely overpowering him before
another surprise guest shows up its
queen moon Flynn calls Romulus jerk
claps and tells him to unfreeze their
dad before they turn his arms into
snakeskin boots clean moon Common dears
the home of Marcos parents to hold an
emergency high magic commission this
five chapter stories shows that families
can be strange in any realm lisa and
pinky fan fiction writer smith s dot 11
combined the worlds at the loud house
and my little pony in this sweet story
about lisa it opens with lisa finding a
small brown box on her front lawn she
opens it to find a little pink pony with
a pink mane and light blue eyes Lisa
decides to name her pinky she hides the
little filly from her siblings and
decides to care for it all on her own
lisa feeds the pony powdered milk and
carrots Lisa thinks that pinky may have
come from an alternate universe she
knows that the pony needs to be with her
own kind
so she researches all the parallel
realities that contain colored ponies
Lisa discovers a land called Equestria
and is convinced it's where pinky
belongs but she must invent a machine to
transport this little pony back to this
place luckily lisa is no stranger to
science projects and inventions it takes
Lisa many years but she finally perfects
the machine that would send pinky home
to Equestria after a long hug and a
tearful goodbye pinkie leaves Lisa and
steps into the machine it zaps pinky
away that even though it was hard to say
goodbye Lisa feels glad that she did the
right thing
what a cute story spider in fans really
seemed to love Ronnie Ann from the loud
house in this fan fiction story written
by smoking wrecker Ronny Ann is bitten
by a radioactive spider you can guess
what happens next
Ronnie n becomes spider and with all
those cool Spidey powers she becomes the
superhero who protects Great Lake City
while also trying to maintain her normal
kid identity Ronnie feels bad about
keeping her new spider abilities from
her good friend Lincoln but she wants to
keep them a secret while she gets a
handle on this new existence
she is living she has to learn how to
we use all of her new powers spider
hands first opponent is the school bully
she must find a way to defeat her
without giving away her true identity
later on it is revealed that there is an
even bigger threat to the town a red car
drives into the city bringing trouble
with it the driver of the car has some
dark intentions for Great Lakes City the
author left us with a major cliffhanger
but they did give us one important
detail about the identity of this
nefarious driver they said it's not just
any character but in fact it is a canon
character Lincoln loud is captain
universe fire slash isn't the first fan
to imagine Lincoln loud in the Marvel
Universe but this particular piece of
fanfiction is a fun ride the story
depicts Lincoln as the first one to ever
receive the power of the Enigma force
this makes him the incredibly powerful
Captain Universe he must navigate
fighting crime handle galactic threats
deal with the daughter of a cosmic
entity and on top of all that try to
have some semblance of a normal life the
Lincoln's life gets a whole lot crazier
the story opens with Lincoln's stopping
a group of bank robbers he quickly
defeats them and turns back into a
normal kid he goes back to hang out with
his sisters for a while but he gets a
vision that scorpion is invading royal
woods so he jumps back into superhero
mode captain universe quickly ripped his
suit and turned him in to the police
then he pairs up with Galacta the
daughter of Galactus and granddaughter
of eternity
she tells Lincoln he is adopted and has
special non-human powers which she shows
him how to use fire slashes story has a
lot of twists and turns the loud dragon
the clever author who goes by a goji
house wrote a story that crosses the
loud house with How to Train Your Dragon
it's quite an interesting tale in this
piece lisa is experimenting with a
chemical that creates a Night Fury the
chemical actually has Night Fury DNA in
it
Lincoln hears a mysterious roar coming
from Lisa's bedroom so he decides to
check it out when he enters Lisa's room
she is surrounded by a strange mist the
mist makes Lincoln transform into a
Night Fury
Lincoln teams up with his sisters to
fight a creature called a monstrous
nightmare
Lincoln gets wounded but they ultimately
team up with other dragons to defeat the
beast they ride on the backs of the
other dragons during the huge battle
flew to Lin Laurie and luan come
together to help Lincoln who is still a
Night Fury
they help heal his wounds and take care
of him the story ends with song lyrics
that read stay close to me you're right
beyond the trees open your eyes and see
this fan fiction piece has it all it's
filled with amazing dragon battles the
love between siblings funny moments and
it ends with a song it's an unexpected
crossover we didn't know we needed the
visitors from troll burg one clever fan
fiction author decided to combine two
animated kit shows to see how the
characters would interact we all know
Lincoln loud and Ronnie Ann as the
friends who bonded after a rocky start
to their friendship Ronnie used to pick
on Lincoln until his sisters intervened
and found out that Ronnie actually likes
Lincoln they became friends and have
been ever since Hilda is a show that is
currently streaming on Netflix it
follows the adventures of a courageous
girl with blue hair she travels a long
way from home which is in a vast magical
and filled with elves and Giants she
journeys to the big city of troll burg
where she makes new friends and meets
mysterious creatures making for many
exciting adventures one clever fan
thought it would be interesting to bring
Hilda and her friend David to visit
Lincoln and Ronnie Ann in royal woods
the author appears to still be working
out the details of the story but it
promises to be interesting and fun who
wouldn't want to read a crossover that
puts Hilda and David in the same world
as Lincoln and Ronnie Ann that just
might be Hilda's the biggest adventure
yet
Lincoln Loud new villain on the block
Frey no Soros wrote a fanfiction story
that combines the plot of the game Lego
DC super villains with the loud house
world in the story Lincoln is kicked out
of the house seiyya sisters Lincoln cold
and wet in the rain finds a portal and
decides to jump in it as Lincoln falls
down the vortex a costume appears in
front of him it's a white rabbit mask
with red and black eyes and a
straitjacket the portal spits Lincoln
out in the city of Metropolis he quickly
discovers that he can run super fast
then suddenly Lincoln his foot in
Strykers Island prison his new
supervillain name is the hare
apparently he got in trouble for
breaking into I've OHS lab there Lex
Luthor freeze the hair and a bunch of
other villains Superman Wonder Woman and
the rest of the Justice League who must
fight and capture the villains and put
them behind bars where they belong
after that Lincoln gets lost a bit still
having him in the story for a little
while
made for a unique crossover story
Pokemon loud crystal now here are two
worlds that wouldn't traditionally go
together but the author king Griffin
definitely thought they should in this
crossover fanfic piece Lincoln goes to
the johto region to begin his journey as
a pokemon trainer but things are made a
bit more difficult for him because all
of his sisters have already been there
for a year that means there are full
year ahead of him in their training he
will also have to deal with a newly
reformed criminal organization which has
been on the rise additionally Lincoln
has a fierce rival who can't wait to put
him in his place the piece is just a
prologue which carries the promise of a
future story but we have a few clues
about what's to come apparently the
reason Lincoln is arriving in the johto
region a full year after his sister's is
because he got sick with a rare illness
he had to stay behind and recover while
his sisters went on without him doctor
said it was a mutated form of Pokhara
that infects humans the doctors cured
him after almost a year of treatment hmm
we wonder if that tidbit of information
will be important for the rest of the
story Lau's on Isla Sorna one crossover
we could never have imagined puts the
loud siblings in the Jurassic Park world
Gogi house wanted to create a story
where the loud kids washed up on East LA
sorna after their cruise ship wrecks off
the coast of Costa Rica the siblings get
separated and must work with the
dinosaurs to be reunited and find their
way home again the loud kids must rely
on the survival skills they've gained
from growing up in a crazy household to
make it in the dinosaur infested jungle
thankfully they are already pretty tough
and resourceful they encounter a family
of t-rexes a group of velociraptors and
a pyro Raptor it's a work in progress so
we don't know for sure how it will end
but we think the loud kids will have a
pretty good chance of making it out
alive if they can stop bickering and
fighting long enough to work together
they could be unstoppable against
dinosaurs or any other forces that try
to get in their way which fanfiction
crossover story was your favorite is
there a crossover story you haven't seen
but would like to read if so tell us in
the comments thanks for watching the
things if you like to loud house then
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up we'll catch you
next time
[Music]